[Music]
our next guest stars in the new prime
video show it's called as we see it and
you should see it the show follows three
20-something roommates who are living on
the autism spectrum and all three
characters are played by actors who
themselves identify as living on the
spectrum actor and comedian yep he's a
comedian rick glassman got lots of jokes
this morning he plays jack a computer
programmer now in this clip jack tells
his aide that's mandy about going out on
a date
hey
how's your date
well i spent half my paycheck on an
overpriced pizza
and they sat us next to an unruly
birthday party with crying babies
so it sounds like it didn't uh i think i
have a girlfriend no
what it would tell me
i think she might be my girlfriend
that's amazing
well i wouldn't get too excited
historically i'll ruin this
yes
welcome to the club rick glassman joins
us now round of applause i love the line
i think i have a girlfriend welcome rick
glassman thank you for having me we're
glad you're here because jack is
navigating new relationships he's
navigating his career he's also trying
to find his independence during all of
this time did you learn anything about
yourself while you were shooting this
i was diagnosed with autism five years
ago five years and one of the worries i
had when booking the show assuming it
went well and i would do this
uh was being a spokesperson for
something that i'm still learning about
and
going through the show and suen and
albert who play my roommates and and so
many of the guest stars who are neuro
diverse characters are played by
neurodiverse actors
i've met so many people
and i've said this before so i get
insecure when i'm repeating stuff but
there's a quote that dr stephen shaw
says if you if you met one person with
autism it means you met one person with
autism yes and that made sense but in
practice meeting so many different
people and oh that's autism i thought
but
you know and just realizing how
literally and metaphorically across the
spectrum it is right and it was just
very validating that
it's not
it's
it you're not defined by a by a thing
right um
but yet we are there is a community of
like people that
i like this word many don't but just a
little weird
that
it was really just nice to connect and i
realized that i realized that i don't
know what autism is
you know i think it's interesting rick
when you said you were just diagnosed
five years ago i can see people looking
at this and saying saying how is that
possible growing up did you think that
there was something i i personally don't
like the word weird you used it i didn't
i don't like that was there was there
something about you growing up that you
thought was different than other people
did you look back now and you got
moments where you yeah i mean i was
you know
different diagnosis of different things
the learning disabled class and then the
other special sub learning disabled
class whatever that was yeah and then i
go to a special school and just and i'm
finding out after the fact of people
taking notes of my behavior that was
taken out of context or
and or
out of my awareness i mean there's a the
one i mean there's there's so many but i
don't know if you guys did do you take a
safety pin
and you could like stick it in the dead
skin and yeah
yeah and then i found out a year later
that it reports that i stabbed myself
and all these things of just being
misunderstood and exaggerated yeah and
exaggerated which isn't an autistic
thing it's just you know sometimes
people don't communicate directly
for many people with autism i think i'll
speak for myself
you need i you need to say
hey you know fix your do this different
or you don't know so the show is very
powerful it's also very funny yes
there are laugh out loud scenes
particularly with your character don't
tell the others but your character is my
favorite
uh
but you make a good point about how uh
you meet an autistic person you've met
one you haven't met everyone so with
that in mind what do you hope viewers
take away from watching the show
i have a very strong stance on speaking
directly and communicating directly
because i need it i've also over the
years since this diagnosis so much
awareness has been brought to me and
i've been able to find these rule books
that have existed that i didn't really
understand i've learned that not
everybody communicates that way not
everybody likes to be communicated to
that way
so
the plan so i have to when i meet
somebody ask that give them that safety
by the way if this if i have a booger
tell me you know like letting people
tell me this thing what i want people to
take from this show is
you know you meet these characters in
the pilot and some things you might like
some might you might not by design um
and in real life then you're like okay
but here it's a show and there's a
narrative and it's entertaining and then
you fall in love with these characters
and on surface you fall in love with the
characters but the reality is you're
proven wrong that oh i just had to get
to know this character
you know that welcome to life baby yeah
um yes we oftentimes say in media and in
hollywood that representation matters i
like to say true representation matters
what truths about autism did this show
get right
here's a moment where i don't feel i
have the credentials to do that so i'm
going to reframe the question and okay
i'm what i'm sure what i like about that
of course although i have to say i since
it came out i've been getting such an
amazing response of people either in the
autistic community or directly connected
to it of really appreciating the
authenticity and i'm so glad there's so
many hands jason came in to create the
show to make this happen
but what i like about it from a possibly
selfish point of view is
i think you are such a beautiful person
there are character traits that i have
in real life especially as a kid that
i was able to bring to this character
that
also it's just a design of the show some
people give more notes than others right
but
they let me do what they let me do what
i felt it was they don't know yeah but i
if that is i mean what's off you know
that's my version of it right yeah right
can i just say this rick your version is
very very good i know they're giving us
a wrap to go i can't say enough about
your performance thank you and the
performance of your co-stars very well
done we thank you for coming i think i
have a hit i really do you have to let
me end with one thing in case this is
the closest i get
hurt live from new york
saturday night i supposed to say cbs
saturday night man this is my moment cbs
morning
thank you rick glassman thank you so
much